reconstituer la cité des dents de scie
de trappes avec une maquette colorée une
fresque sur l'histoire des yvelines pour
cette journée spéciale fêtes de
l'histoire les archives départementales
ont organisé plusieurs ateliers dans la
découverte de leur activité cette année
nous avons dédié la journée au
territoire à son lieu d'habitat c'était
l'occasion de découvrir les ressources
dont nous disposons sur ce sujet et puis
aussi de permettre au public de
découvrir la ville de saint quentin sur
laquelle nous sommes implantés au
travers de parcours de visite de jeu de
piste et de maquettes qui sont
disponibles chez nous pour cette édition
les archives se sont associés aux musées
de la ville de saint quentin en yvelines
ils ont proposé des visites de quartier
et un stand avec notamment des jeux pour
enfants les deux entités se complètent
pour faire découvrir l'histoire locale
au public par exemple au new day alors
tous les cartes postales ou visites et
aux archives à la maquette du quartier
en question donc on peut vraiment
travailler en complément a été l'un avec
l'autre thématique centrale le
territoire et les lieux d'habitat une
façon pour les visiteurs de redécouvrir
leur ville
je suis pas venu chercher quelque chose
en particulier celui voir comment les
gens travaillaient
de voir quels matériaux il utilisait
pour faire leurs recherches
parce que moi c'est quelque chose qui
m'a toujours beaucoup intéressé
l'histoire d'un lieu l'histoire d'une
ville l'histoire des gens aussi et s'il
ya bien un endroit où on peut voir ça
c'est aux archives dernières photos
avant de partir avec des cartes postales
anciennes pour garder un souvenir de
cette journée est du passé